[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment news i'm
heather ruse and i'm anna wave and this
is your news for monday october 16th
so last week there are a couple of
things that came out after we had films
that we weren't able to talk about that
we so need to talk about and the one
that is just personally most important
to me is the Star Wars last Jedi trailer
oh my gosh guys I was so excited there
were just inhuman noises coming from
because I was watching this trailer
there were porks there is an even versus
phasma Lynn has an imperial uniform on
we saw ray training with Luke there was
a whole bunch of really cool kylo stuff
thrown in there Mark Hamill looked
terrified the entire trailer time I was
just freaking out and I'm so excited for
this film the hype is so real for us uh
a lot of people have already dissected
this debate so we're not going to bore
you with our own interpretations what
things could possibly mean yes we
understand they probably tricked us into
believing scenes cut together were a
single scene or have they double-bluffed
you is it actually the scene they're
showing you I think maybe it is the
double bottle exactly also that came out
this last week was the Justice League
trailer which was not as exciting it was
fine it was fine
it was a little forgettable we had to
rewatch it because we forgot what
happened
yeah it's action-packed it's telling you
what's going on we've seen who all's in
it so I really believe we didn't really
learn much from this trailer anything
new that we needed to learn it didn't
seem like the tone was much different
from the other ones even though we know
the tone in the movie is gonna be
changed so we're still gonna see it
we're still in I'm excited to see it I'm
more excited that there's a potential
for someone to live streaming on
Instagram
ruffalo oh good you never Thor nice nice
job good job mark ruffalo in other
superhero movie news this week the
Batman 66 animated feature Batman vs
two-face came out which is notably one
of Adam West's last performances that he
was able to record as Batman and in an
interview Burt Ward came out and said
that if this movie does well if Batman
vers two-face does well there is a
possibility a high possibility of more
Batman 66 films coming out without Adam
West what which just seems like so not
empty sick awful awful idea I don't even
know what actor would be willing to try
to take up that mantle right who would
be willing to replace Burt who who would
be willing to replace Adam West as
Batman would you recast as a different
voice would you rather hear someone try
to copy his voice that's so awkward I
yeah personally I think that they just
need to keep making the comic exactly
it's a great way to keep that universe
alive because it is a fun universe it's
a great way to keep it alive while still
honoring Adam West and not having to
recast him right so more comics I have
some no movies that's about that yeah
another thing happening with superhero
movies is we finally have a release date
for the channing tatum gambit movie yeah
yeah that's still happen finally being
pushed through i guess and the release
dates in an odd turn of events is
Valentine's Day 2019 so February 14th
2019 which seems like a weird move are
they just going the Deadpool route cuz
Deadpool was the og with those fake
Valentine and they were great it's
already done did really well done to the
best that it could possibly be done
mm-hmm I don't know man I'm gonna need
to see more about this gambit phone
before I feel any positivity towards it
because it sounds weird well
Channing Tatum is working on his Cajun
accent
so there's that good job buddy speaking
of absence of other dialects that you're
not BBC is doing a three-part miniseries
to the American classic little women
which i think is a very odd turn of
events it's an American classic
however the writer is Heidi Thomas of
Call the Midwife so great writing my
kind of amount board also they're really
into period dramas over I don't know but
if it's anything in the direction of the
series of Downton Abbey which I loved
man they might really be able to
understand the gravity and also some of
the levity and some of just the beauty
of the sets one of the twelve sets that
Britain has but it's gonna be a really
interesting take to see it from that
perspective Angela Lansbury is going to
be playing aunt March yes which I'm on
to March 100 I'm 100% on board with that
lutely yes and the four lead march girls
which we got the production and photo
from this week they look fine they're
relatively unknown some of them have a
couple credits under them but they're
not big names by any means so I'm kind
of excited to see some lesser-known
women little women yeah I think the BBC
would be able to do this justice and it
would be a really interesting way for a
new generation of kids to be introduced
a little women if you didn't see the 90s
one man yeah also this week the
Winchester film's release date got moved
up two weeks in February so it's now
going to be come out February 2nd of
2018 um which is weird because usually
we hear movies are pushed back but hey
you're raring to go and want to get
those box office sales in before black
panther do what you do
they've also renamed the film it's no
longer just Winchester they've renamed
it Winchester the house that ghosts
built if you want some spooky fun for
October because it's all Halloween
season look into the Winchester
your house because it's a very
interesting story or go see this film
when it comes out yeah February because
Helen Mirren is starring into right are
we just the lead lady who all the sudden
loses her husband and child and he
decides to build 24 hours a day seven
days a week because if possibly
grief-stricken this or because ghosts
told her to do it what so it sounds like
with the title change they're definitely
going the supernatural route with the
storytelling and less like right right
less psychotic and more supernatural or
maybe both
another spooky thing that was announced
this week is an Addams Family animated
movie it was just announced they have a
director and a writer so the writer is
Pamela pettler who was the writer for
corpse bride and monster house which are
both great spooky Halloween movie is so
some good writing hopefully will be in
there and the director is going to be
Conrad Vern Vernon who is the
co-director of sausage party so I don't
know weird we're that's gonna be like
well he's done an animated film that did
well so yeah but it seems like sausage
party an Addams Family are not
compatible I don't disagree yeah I've
got faith for it and I'm very excited
for more Addams Family I love Addams
Family Wednesday you own a piece of my
black little heart definitely something
that impacted both of us in the 90s
although very exciting news we have no
information at all about a release date
or the animators or anything like that
the style of it but it's excited another
movie we got a trailer for this week was
the New Mutants yeah and we knew that it
was going to be kind of a horror
thriller vibe they had said that but
dang this was a straight-up horror movie
that we got a trailer for it was very
creepy it's almost like a haunted house
there
tracted an asylum so rather than it
being you know the home for gifted
students it's an asylum they're having
experiments performed on them there are
weird beats going on and creeping in on
them yeah it wasn't my favorite thing
because it's gory I don't I don't like
jump horror movies I know what I don't
so I'm a little weary of this now
although the cast looks amazing yeah I'm
really excited for aria
I think it was really cool trailer and I
also just sort of gotten the vibe of
like Legion meets American Horror Story
and if you put that with Mike that
sounds awesome
I'm totally I'm yeah I'm a little weary
well other scary and stranger things
that are coming are the Easter
interesting season 2 trailer that we
just got full of pride in of her team
and it was incredible eleven looks
amazing girl oh good I'm very very
excited for season two is a super well
done trailer we got to see some
different Hawkins shots of some like
upside down this and maybe the Dimmick
again or a big giant octopus monster
with yeah shadow yeah there's some scary
stuff happening and it's just teasin in
all the right ways and there's even a
new addition to the cast which is the
new female cat that we don't know
anything about yet so we're gonna have
to wait and see on October 27th when
it's released and in the meantime this
bro has a card game or thing which is
eggo waffle shapes weirdest collab
bottle gourd a card game yeah and you
there's seven different characters you
can play as and then there's different
things that can happen to you you can be
sent to the underground or reversed back
to normal plane of existence
there's tons going on I think the
packaging right cool the box art looks
cool I definitely try it out but it
sounds like a weird concept for a
cartoon and there's no actual waffles
that you get with it so
disappointing mm-hmm lovely no sorry
don't eat these waffles I think that's
gonna be it from us here guys there's
anything we missed from this week let us
know in the comments down below if you
feel strongly about anything any of the
trailer drops or postal releases let us
know as well otherwise how they were can
people find you on social media you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
flash other roofs and as always you can
find me on Facebook as Ayanna Wade for
everywhere else and has awesome Ayana so
we will catch you next week in the
meantime egg could you beam us up
[Applause]
you